außerirdisches leben auf dem land und
titan gilt bei vielen fachleuten als
sehr wahrscheinlich auch wenn die
grundlagen des lebens hier ganz andere
sind als auf der erde ein schwedisches
forschungsteam will jetzt herausgefunden
haben dass sie zellen auf diesem
himmelskörper komplett anders aufgebaut
sein könnten als die zellen hier auf
unserer erde auch deren funktion könnte
sich extrem von dem unterscheiden was
wir bislang kennen krieg zum science
fiction gibt es spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen der titan ist der
größte der saturnmonde und er gilt als
der erdähnlichste himmelskörper im
sonnensystem er besitzt eine atmosphäre
einen wahren kern sehen regen und wolken
sowie canyons seine oberfläche ist so
groß wie die kontinente afrika europa
und asien zusammen auch weil der titan
eine atmosphäre besitzt vergleichen in
fachleute oft mit der frühen erde doch
auf dem saturnmond ist es extrem kalt
kein wunder schließlich ist er zehn mal
weiter von der sonne entfernt als die
erde
so sind eisige temperaturen von minus
180 grad celsius keine seltenheit in
seinen gewässern befindet sich außerdem
kein wasser sondern flüssiges methan und
metern ein gemisch daraus füllt die seen
meere und flüsse es verdunstet feld
wieder als regen vom himmel und somit
verfügt der titan über einen
flüssigkeits kreislauf der vergleichbar
ist mit dem wasserkreislauf auf der erde
die kohlenwasserstoffe metern und tätern
und andere organische moleküle gelten
als bausteine für das leben und so wird
der titan oft auch als
aussichtsreichster kandidat für
außerirdisches leben gehandelt
ein schwedisches forschungsteam hat
jetzt computersimulationen genutzt um zu
analysieren wie die zellen auf dem titan
gestaltet sein könnten konkret gehen die
fachleute in der aktuellen studie davon
aus dass potenzielles leben auf dem
titan keine zellmembran besitzen könnte
bot dies widerspricht allem was wir von
der erde kennen hier sind zellmembranen
überlebenswichtig da sie das innere der
zelle und alle teile die sich darin
befinden schützen zellkern die
organellen und das zytoplasma werden
somit also vor dem einfluss anderer
zellen und dem außenraum bewahrt eine
zellmembran hier auf der erde um
schließt jede menschliche und tierische
zelle und besteht aus einer
doppelten lage von lipiden vereinfacht
gesagt handelt es sich hierbei um fette
zellmembran auf der erde ermöglichen es
nicht nur das lebensnotwendige stoffe
aufgenommen werden sie gewährleisten
auch die abgabe von abfallprodukten nach
außen fachleute bezeichnen die nach
außen gerichtete seite der zellmembran
als polar und hydrophil also wasser
lieben nach innen ist sie dagegen um
polar zellmembran die auf dem titan zu
finden sein könnten müssten nach ansicht
des forschungsteams dementsprechend
anders herum aufgebaut sein
denn die dort vorherrschenden
kohlenwasserstoffe sind unklar eine
membran also die nach außen hin und
voller wirkt könnte
mit dem etat metern gemischt des titels
wechselwirken bereits vor einigen jahren
hatte ein us forschungsteam eine studie
zu diesem thema veröffentlicht die
fachleute hatten damals eine
theoretische zellmembran mit der
bezeichnung absurd uhr simuliert diese
besteht aus organischen stickstoff und
könnte selbst in den eiskalten gewässern
des täters existieren und dort ihren
zweck erfüllen
der studie zufolge könnte sie ähnlich
flexibel und stabil gestaltet seit wie
ihre irdischen gegenstücke diese
erkenntnis hatte die fachwelt damals
enorm erstaunt ihre schwedischen
kolleginnen und kollegen dagegen halten
es für wahrscheinlich dass potenzielles
leben auf dem saturnmond titan gar keine
zellmembran besitzt das forschungsteam
nutzte computersimulation und
analysierte sowie sich zellmembran mit
umgedrehter polarität bei denen auf dem
titan vorherrschenden bedingungen
verhalten würden demnach sprechen die
extrem niedrig temperatur auf dem saturn
und gegen die existenz biologischer
makromoleküle denn diese wären aufgrund
der äußeren bedingungen auf diesem
himmelskörper quasi bewegungsunfähig die
temperaturen lassen also eher auf
lebensformen schließen die auf kleineren
molekülen basieren wenn diese jedoch von
einer zellmembran umgeben wären würden
diese ebenso eine ausbreitung verhindern
so die hypothesen der aktuellen studie
die fachwelt reagiert erstaunt und auch
skeptisch über diese theorie so zum
beispiel dirk schulze makuch von der tu
berlin
ich bezweifele diese schlussfolgerung da
mir die anwesenheit von zellmembran
weiterhin als essentiell für die
aufrechterhaltung des ungleichgewichts
zwischen dem zellinneren und äußeren
erscheint ohne diese gäbe es nichts dass
dem verlust wichtiger organischer
moleküle an die umgebung der zelle
verhindern würde
aus diesem grund glaube ich fest dass
das leben auf der erde auf titan und
anderswo auf die integrität seiner
kleinsten einheit der zelle angewiesen
ist die wissenschafts community ist sich
allerdings in einer sache einig im
besten fall könnte eine direkte sonden
mission zum titan solche fragen klären
die nasa beispielsweise plant ja die
mission dragonfly die bereits im jahr
2026 staaten soll bereits acht jahre
später im jahr 2034 soll die hightech
drohnen namens libelle diesen saturnmond
erkunden
dieses autonome fluggerät ist rund drei
meter groß und verfügt über vier doppel
rotor dadurch wird sie sich mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 36 kilometern pro
stunde über die titan oberfläche bewegen
können insgesamt soll sie laut plan
in der dreijährigen missions- zeit mehr
als 175 kilometer weit an verschiedene
orte fliegen und die landschaften des
titan und ihre chemie erkundigen damit
würde dragonfly eine längere strecke
zurücklegen als alle bisherigen planeten
rover zusammen dazu thomas zu buchen von
der nasa der titan ist anders als alle
anderen orte im sonnensystem und dragon
fleisch ist wie keine andere mission
dragonfly wird eine welt besuchen die
von einer großen vielfalt an organischen
molekülen erfüllt ist sie sind die
bausteine des lebens und könnten uns den
ursprung des lebens selbst verraten
gibt es leben auf titan das fragt sich
auch asto comics tv anklicken anschauen
und den coolen kanal von tim abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran